hello everybody I'm so excited to be
talking to y'all today hello how are you
now I've got the opportunity to chat
with Miss Viva before it's nice to see
you again hello good to see thank you
for your support of course of course um
so let's get right to it um what brought
the four of y'all together for this show
for crown that would be our amazing
Creator James deos who is also the
creator of in the black network uh
Selena and I were on a show on uh
another network uh cocktails were Queen
right them people uh cocktails were
queens and uh we were unfortunately
canceled and we were actually really sad
because we really thought that we had um
really got a following so James didn't
give up on us he told us it wasn't over
and a couple of months later he gave us
both a call and said hey I want to start
a new show I'm going to start my own
networ which we congratulate him on
Having the courage and um here we are
with with crown our first show is going
to come out October 2nd in the black
network. TV uh coming out at midnight
every Monday you'll get new episodes and
if you miss us at midnight you can catch
us the next day all day because we're
gonna be streaming on all kind of
platforms I love it I love that and I
love that this is a new network yes for
us by us I think that so important yeah
so so so important in this day and age
like now is the time um so I have
another question for all of y'all if you
could pick two words to describe the
show what would they be and why real
talk yeah okay um and and not like you
know those two like how we say it in
slang that's real talk it's going to be
a lot of that you going to be doing
through the TV you know what I'm saying
or through your phone or whever what
have you um it's real this is this is a
show that is based upon reality real not
reality TV reality real life reality so
real talk are my two words yes I'm going
say relatable and empowerment like I
want us to be relatable I think what
you're going to realize yeah we all here
you should have saw us an hour ago child
you know they done put this wig on so
good in my makeup so good but there's
levels right I was Kindra now I'm KRA G
but you're going to get a lot of KRA
when you're with all the ladies and I
want to say empowerment because my goal
is when you watch something hopefully it
will inspire your life in some way to
make a change or to do something
different I would say real and raw a
transparency just because we will be
sharing certain aspects of our lives uh
you'll get a glimpse of some personal
experiences for me I like to talk about
relationships so I'm definitely going to
be real honest about those topics but um
and then the ladies Kendra is
unavailable you know she'll be able to
speak from
that but why are we why are we labeled
by our Our dating status you did
that merging
it look at I'm just giving them a
glimpse of what they'll get cuz that you
said don't put that on your life oh yeah
don't put that on my life that's what
you said put rich on my life well yeah
then Selena she's married and Vivica is
single and happy right I say that I
wanted to going to be grown women talk
yeah yes grown women
I love it yes more of that again I I
keep saying we need more of it because
it's so true we need more of that we
need people to keep it real we need
honesty we need truth so I love all of
those responses I'm all for empowerment
and I appreciate that um I do have a
question specifically um about cocktails
and queens um can you provide more
insight into why it was cancelled
actually we are not at Liberty to um
communicate why it was cancelled um but
we will say that you know and I think I
speak for Viva as well we were sad that
it was canceled it was not something
that we wanted um but you know we
actually very surprised we were
surprised but we would like to focus on
in the black Network and our progression
um it's going to be just as good if not
even better so um cocktails with the
Queens was a great chapter an amazing
host we love ladies but we are you know
embarking upon a new chapter and and
that's what we'd like to focus on if
that's okay absolutely absolutely you
know I just had to ask because you know
it does have a huge following and so I'm
excited for the idea that that following
will get to come to this new network
trust me they would leave every day I
would get comments where's cocktails
with Queens well guess what Darlings
we're back we down to the in the black
that's where the people are back and in
the black in the black that's that's the
point and I I'm W
everyone
y I'm saying I I want everyone to hear
in the black so that they know like
cocktail Queens may be over but I'm
gonna get that fixed and it's gonna be
even better that part absolutely we
stream every we have a new episode every
Monday night uh premiering October 2nd
uh at midnight and if you missed us
we're going to be streaming on a lot of
different platforms so you can catch us
whenever you like We Love Options We
Love Options
so uh I have one more question from and
I'd like to hear from all of you from
your personal perspectives what would
you like the viewers watching to gain
when they're watching crowned um the
truth I think the truth I think um I
think our big audience will be black
women and I don't think any of us will
be successful without the support of
black women black women rule the world
and always and I wouldn't be successful
without the support of black women but I
think we got to have like we've been
saying the theme is real talk and I
don't think we always give each other
the truthful advice we give the nice
advice we give the advice that sounds
good the advice that you want to hear
but um I know my role in particular I
want to give you the advice that's going
to set you free that's going to lead you
on a road of happiness and it might not
always be nice but it's going to be what
you need to hear so like take your
medicine so you can get better you want
to be sick the rest of your life might
be a little bitter going down that's
right robot testing let tell you
something robot rob it fix
everything um for me it's it's living
room it's the living room you know I
want you to I want people to take away
um a comfortable safe space like we in
the living room talking Hey listen right
now in social media I know from what I
can see it's a lot of gimmicky little
conversations that rhyme you know what
I'm saying it's very and the hat in the
cat set and then they clip that and then
they put that all in the world and it's
like ooh she said that it's a lot of
that well we're not doing that we're
coming from actual life experiences
actual things and and really speaking in
a place where people can act from so so
that people can actually heal from and
actually get a aha moment from or a
revelation or progression from that to
me for me that's my goal I want people
to have to come back to see us because
it's that much of a fix you know they
they they need it that much yeah I'll
piggy back off of Selena Enlightenment
and encouragement and also we're going
to have a musical guest every episode uh
where we're going to discover some new
artists that maybe you don't know of
that we'll be able to give them exposure
some of our fave R&B artists like Leela
Hathaway is going to be on our initial
uh show that our first show that comes
out so uh it I just wanted to be
refreshing for our culture to see their
Queens shining now I would just say a
different perspective we'll talk about
different topics and we all have
different perspectives we come from
different walks of life so you'll be
able to hear it from not just my
perspective but Kendra and Selena and
Viva so I think that's important in
terms of just navigating issues and
things that we deal with as black women
amazing I am so grateful for y'all and
for this show I'm so excited for it to
come out on October 2nd thank you so
much for taking this time to chat with
me